c'est le point d'impact d'un des tir qui
se sont abattus sur novo luganz
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un poste
avancé du commandement de l'armée
ukrainienne
l'ancien garage de machinerie agricole
est occupé par les forces ukrainiennes
depuis la guerre en 2014
à son général
Vladimir résumé a été atteint par le
projectile
tout va bien tout va bien lui dit une
des secouristes pour le rassurer le
jeune homme de 25 ans a survécu à ses
blessures mais on a dû l'amputer
Vladimir est l'un des quatre soldats
Ukrainiens blessés aujourd'hui deux
autres dont un officier ont été tués
comme nous apprêtons à regagner le
bâtiment principal du poste les tirs
reprennent
[Musique]
vite on nous met à l'abri
au cours de cette nouvelle attaque
forçant même le ministre de l'Intérieur
en visite dans les tranchées à courir
aux abris
parce que les tirs ont repris le genre
de violation des accords de Mint que les
soldats disent voir de plus en plus ici
des tirs d'armes interdites à quelques 5
à 10 km de leur position
tout au long de la ligne de contact avec
les rebelles séparatistes dans un
cessez-le-feu qui se transforme en
chimère les autorités ukrainiennes ont
rapporté 98 violations du 16 et le feu
aujourd'hui seulement
les observateurs internationaux
qualifient l'augmentation des derniers
jours de spectaculaire
au risque de donner l'image d'un
président absent en pleine crise c'est
un Munich que c'est rendu le président
ukrainien volodime ski pour plaider avec
l'Occident il a répété la demande de
sanction immédiate contre la Russie sur
Disney pour vraiment aider l'Ukraine ça
ne sert à rien dit-il de parler de
possible d'invasion nous allons défendre
notre pays que ce soit le 16 février le
1er mars ou le 31 décembre
à Moscou c'est une image inversée que
l'on présente de la situation accusant
les forces ukrainiennes d'être à
l'origine de l'intensification des tirs
Vladimir Poutine envoyait visiblement un
message en assistant à des tests de
missiles doté de la capacité nucléaire
chez les séparatistes dans la république
autoproclamée de danietsk on se prépare
à ce qu'on écrit comme une situation
critique les autorités ont ordonné la
mobilisation des hommes en âge de
combattre alors que des milliers de
femmes et d'enfants ont pris la route
vers la Russie
les accusations voulant que l'armée
ukrainienne est sur le point d'attaquer
son catégoriquement démenti du côté
ukrainien de la frontière c'est faux
nous n'avons aucun plan de reconquête a
dit l'avis première ministre c'est la
Fédération russe qui retient la
population en otage
ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada Nova